[Musique]
c'est tout si on croise quelqu'un c'est
soit quelqu'un qui travaille pour le Bye
Bye ou soit c'est des valeurs c'est dans
les studios de l'ancienne Maison de
Radio-Canada qu'a été enregistrée et
monté en théorie pour une dernière fois
le Bye Bye 2022 le septième réalisé par
Simon Ollivier texto c'est extrêmement
touchant travailler à la vieille tour en
ce moment c'est complètement
désuet mais c'est des beaux studios ça
travaille vraiment bien c'est un peu
très en fait qu'on va perdre ça il
faisait vraiment un froid parce qu'il
chauffe un peu moins vu que pour
personne mais les gens qui sont là ont
quand même besoin de chaleur même si son
peu outre la nostalgie des bye bye Passy
c'est ajouter quelques défis pour
l'équipe de production
de Radio-Canada moi je prends pas
l'ascenseur les escaliers roulants sont
brisés on marche plus c'est bon pour la
santé je suis sûr que très bientôt je
vais voir un chevreuil dans le corridor
puis je serai pas surpris vous êtes au
courant que l'autre selon le chroniqueur
MCG qui fait partie de la revue de fin
d'année d'Infoman depuis une vingtaine
d'années on peut encore rire de tout
suffit de trouver le bon angle avec la
tête il faut voir les devenus Potter pas
juste une émission humoristique
l'émission satirecte l'émission qui
parle de ce qui se passe c'est sûr que
dans des sujets dont tout le monde parle
en ce moment la guerre en Ukraine qui a
débuté en 2022 le fait aussi que la
pandémie c'est presque arrêté en 2022
mais il faut quand même en parler Tchin
Tchin en plus du Bye Bye de la revue le
public pourra aussi compter sur
l'émission de France Baudouin en direct
du jour de l'an
cette
enregistré devant spectateurs cette
fois-ci et les sujets d'actualité comme
à l'habitude ne manquent pas les choix
qui sont toujours difficiles choisir nos
sketchs ça a été difficile ensuite
choisir les sketchs qu'on joue qu'on
joue pas c'est difficile et après
l'enregistrement choisir les sketchs 10
9 nouveau studio ou ancien une chose est
sûre le décompte lui se termine à minuit
ici Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal
[Applaudissements]